she's we can talk of Impala forces shape
the geometry I think I will address my
speech in English even if since not that
not yet but early next month we will
have a fathered H million inhabitant in
in Europe from woman their home language
is English and for the 504 remaining
fellow citizen mean it will not be
English that's a consequence of the back
seat so we know the program it's a fact
it's a fact
so you will need probably to adjust
yourself we can and occupation sloppy
this f50 we put a poly from say how long
poly de piqi so tell about not care me
at the one envoy or norm come Longley he
would not belong bow Allah will give a
battalion ugly the what to tell you
first that I'm sorry and vague I'm very
happy to see it with each of you I
recognize many faces that I know but
most of them not yet but you will know
me because I I have the intention to
handle disability extremely seriously so
we love of course I'm glad because I'm
just at the end of the process of this
to me to today's all my colleagues was a
commissioner and everybody was
congratulate you saying how important
you are
which is true and now I can say why I'm
not too happy but of course to progress
to progress together but first apologize
because I wanted to be to be here with
you yesterday but unfortunately I had to
I mean unfortunately I had to be a
endeavours for one hour because we had
with a president from the lion a very
important meeting with the President of
the United States and she wanted to be
to be to be here with her and with
colleague Finnegan that's why I had to
to postpone my speech but I know that
you had a great great two days and and
of course my first message to you is
that I'm extremely happy to be here
obviously this is a very important
moment for our industry for space
industry everything you do and of course
important for us because we invest a lot
of money in Europe in the Commission
matter everywhere as for Member States
and of course that's extremely extremely
important you achieved fantastic success
that's abuse and I'm extremely impressed
to tell you the truth proud of about
Galileo of course ignored Copernicus all
these are of course now references and
and I know it was not it was not
something which was written but at the
end of the day thanks to all of you we
we did it and that's of course something
which makes me very very proud as being
now in charge in the European Commission
of space few successes but important
Copernicus Europe's eyes for us said
Robertson dots by offering now accurate
data of the planet seven days per week
24 hours that's an amazing achievement
which is recognized worldwide and use
worldwide and and and his valued also
worldwide so that's a very impressive
achievement and of course with
Copernicus Europe as probably one of the
biggest data providers in the world and
you know that that has extremely
important for all of us and especially
for me but for for our continent for
everyone
with more than 12 terabyte of of high
quality that forgot to and we are
looking for high quality data in what we
want to prepare for for Europe free and
open every day why would you keep is
absolutely clear here to maintain the AU
autonomous capacity to observe us and to
position Copernicus as the edge of the
technical frontier so of course we will
continue to do what has to be done and I
will act especially integrate within
Copernicus and we always talk about it
with with my teams or the capacity that
quantum technologies could bring to
develop new services one who know me
know that I have a passion for quantum
technologies and quantum physics you
know that better so we will will push
this that's an extremely important
development the new frontier for many
services and innovation which will drive
our society at large for the next
decades but words so I asked my to
direct Royds the the one from defense in
space and the one from digital connect
to work together and here to enhance our
capacities to earth to enhance again
everything we can do for the new
generation of Copernicus so gone Galileo
Galileo the past year have been
dedicated to the deployment of Galileo
which is gentle development but also the
infrastructure and software and gorilla
is now of course up and running for more
than two years and while still in its
initial mode service mode the accuracy
of the Leo goes I think beyond was
expected by many including our American
friends but not only so that's a
fantastic success and achievement and it
shows that despite I remember the
skepticism at the beginning where this
program has been launched we you did it
it's a tremendous achievement and of
course we'll continue to to develop
Galileo we have more than 1 billion
users on the planet and I know very well
that this number is growing every other
day preview is of course not smartphone
your original cars it helps also to save
lives and I saw the announcement that
you have made I think to yesterday or
the day before which is very important
to activate the 112 emergency number
also ecosystem in cars and of course is
for huge service so my objective for
Galileo is extremely clear first to
continue the playing the Lido in order
to reach the full operational capacity
as soon as possible so going to continue
improving the precision of Galileo with
now a target of 20 centimeters which
will make again the best in the world so
to prepare already the second generation
video in order to stay ahead in the
technological race and of course the
transition batch procurement is ongoing
and all that and force to ensure the
smooth development of encrypted signal
because Galileo is also I just remind
you this a strategic asset designed to
be also used for military and civil
security purposes Timo you know this we
spoke already a lot of this so with
Galileo
I will come back on some governance
issues we may have time now I'm on the
good news pattern so so that's a fun
part and so with Galileo I will not
forget don't worry
we tell you when Copernicus the place of
Europe in the global landscape is
absolutely very strong and by the way is
our signal and and and this is my second
message because of this we just cannot
afford to capitalize only on our past
achievement we need to invest in the
future and to get organized deliver more
but we are Mathieu now
differently more but differently but we
will continue to spend a lot of money
you can count on me I will be extremely
tough in the negotiation of the budget
it's a lot of money that will put on the
table it means that we will have to work
of course better and probably
differently the space sector is
undergoing massive change worldwide and
you know this much much better than me
of course and it goes through an
important industry decision process the
result of which is that doing space is
of course cheaper and more accessible so
of course that's a reality we are in and
now and that's why also we are not in a
business as usual mod environment
anymore
that's over indeed in this matter it
will be obviously at least for what we
are responsible to is before and then
after
the kondalian commission i just remind
you that the Commission has proposed but
you know this of course much better than
me 16 billion euros in the program
21:27 I just saw my colleague
Commissioner Han to make sure that we
will be totally aligned with the
negotiation and I know it will be tough
but you can count on me this is
extremely important and by the way in
exchange I will give the commitment that
we will do more
with what we received from our taxpayers
and the member states and that we will
enhance our capacity to work much better
to be there in a bit rely on Chappell if
you ever lie of course we will have to
work also extremely close with the
Parliament we have many many I was very
impressed by the way preparing my
hearing to realize that we have many MPs
playing a big role and extremely
well-prepared having the passion and I
learned a lot by listening to them by
the way I learned a lot also in some
ideas to enhance the way we could use
the money and the way we could work
together so gone I want all the project
that we will develop together to evolve
in order to develop new services for
instance security of course extremely
important fighting climate we have some
IDs of course here climate change
optimizing our use of raw materials
using the full potential of quantum
technologies both in term of
entanglement or security and but also in
term of have salvation and we'll come
back maybe on this high of time third I
believe that it is absolute imperative
as the youth space sector adapt to the
new realities geopolitical strategy
industrial and technology on the third
point there are several dimension that I
would like to to highlight with you the
first element is a that space is an
enabler of security and defence and I
know very well that it has been a taboo
for Europe for a long time one of the
big achievement
of one of them many we kept him in the
UN Commission has been to establish this
European defense fund my level I was a
little bit small part of the thinking
behind this and the beauty of it is of
course at first we need of course to
take more credit enhancement understand
better that we need to handle more and
more our defence together but of course
we know that here each of the members
that have the own history future and see
the very sensitive and complex subject
that we have to expect while it's
important to move forward and this is in
this contact that the deference fund has
been created in other words allowing
every single country of the Member
States to participate to a difference
project they will make sure net
selection that everyone will participate
so that everyone will feel concerned
with the preparation of a true or more
important to defense industry and of
course space is an important subject in
the defence era and we know we know this
because of course you will all know that
Galileo for example as defense dimension
we know also that Copernicus can serve
security missions and that we know that
this train will be of course staying in
the future so this is why we will
possibly lunch to new initiatives it's
not a surprise to you the first one is a
space situational awareness so-called
SSI system to avoid collision and debris
on key satellites and this is a reason
things that we need to handle battle
with it will be difficult to handle
alone
so that's where we may need some
cooperation it's a very important
subject but at least we need to have our
own
program to be better also to both
strongly with others remember when you
want to cooperate you must have
something to offer so we will need to
cooperate that's obvious it's impossible
to me that will be to do it alone but in
order to propose something we need to
have our garment you know we will work
on this because there's some things that
I want to learn very quickly it is
extremely important to be part of this
global Robert subject as maybe founder
precursor of first european space
traffic management system and then be
part of what will be done on a worldwide
basis
the second important topic is of course
the governmental satellite communication
so-called gossiped come although this
initiative will be done to provide to
the member states support in
communication secure communication
police border protection diplomatic cops
seal protection during crisis for
example and everything which would be
extremely important and here again cable
when we will launch some initiative is a
difference fun we make sure that some of
the project could be dual maybe some
will be only for space we'll see but it
is something that we will look at
extremely carefully another second
element which is of course extremely
important is that there will not be a
credible space policy without an
independent access to space and I know
that you discuss this a lot during this
these two days we have of course
demonstrated demonstrated in europe our
excellency
when it comes to two lunches like
science it's
legacy which would ensure you have
autonomous access to space in the years
to come and of course it is son tried to
support the party to support the
development of these ranchers and the
Commission was as you all know the first
institutional client of in6 we just
pre-booked four other iron 620 sepia
heat units of Galileo as you probably
know at the EU level and thanks to the
provisional grid in the space program
wouldn't be able to use the EU budget to
support Europe an election industry and
we are ready to aggregate our
institutional demand to support gran
infrastructures and the deployment of
new technology however and here also
it's not a surprise to you in light of
the development of the u.s. Ranchers
which are by the way that we subsidize
it is equally important to already
prepare the next generation of your pan
launchers so that we do not miss the
raziel ability technology or any other
disruptive technologies let's come to
myself my third element one of my
favorite one together with quantum
governance governance
so to develop the strategy we need to
work differently and I'm ready to spend
a lot of time with each of you first to
understand went when extremely well in
the past and have received a lot of
subsistence already mentioned a lot and
so on to see if we're in the past some
errors to understand why we already
started loose on land are always
extremely important especially in the
phase where we have in order to correct
- correct
what has to be corrected so good news is
that I am an outsider which is
absolutely not your case so you will
benefit hopefully of my fresh eyes and
also my passion as a former professor of
governance at our University
how we could improve based on success
and error so we will you understand that
something I understood and discover are
just not acceptable or not acceptable
anymore
and if we want to be successful we have
to invent a new way to to work together
the Commission of course National Space
Agency's is a GSA industry I got some
training when I was young because I have
been an enemy starter for many years of
look nice I could already spot training
I was icing for five or six years it is
written in such a weakness sometimes
also be inverted did you pick this
article bjl a possible Hawaii when it's
20 DiBiase especially you have a
negative element passio logical
resonator three more fantastic past you
know extraordinaire exacto
you see Alyssa MOFA but no everything
will be more costly and we will have
much more project so we will have to to
to learn I don't want to come back on
the governance issue that we had in the
I fix I start to understand what
happened
I'm not yet hundred percent sure of the
responsibilities but I will discover and
and then my job will not be to finish
anybody but to propose and will together
on yoga and so that this will not happen
to good news that to tell you the truth
in July I wasn't expecting to be here
one day to give you the speech now join
September 9 October and as I November
but here I am
that's life and the canoe is that when I
saw this news callaloo no service for
one week when business users you know
what was my first reaction the system
has been act by hackers and I was afraid
because I know the vulnerability and
this is a subject I know a little bit
orbiter and to tell you to so much as we
thought it was a maybe one of the reason
no the good news is just because we
worked buddies that's easy that's easy
much more is it doesn't do them to track
a hacker
so that's thanks God we will be able to
fix it we'll be able to fix it but we
will have also to on to to change some
rules also because I heard when when I
was discussing already to do to deep
dive
everything you do you know mr.
Commissioner you know we provide
services so we need to in travel zero
default and I'm coming in an industry
where we are where you need to do to
deserve it usually for yes but you know
we are still in development and come on
no no no we're Cindy repin so we have
excuses no we are not still in
development
maybe yes but I don't care we are
providing services now we have to change
this we are providing extremely critical
services to our European fellows and
industry and by the way not only we have
to be zero default and believe me yes I
can tell you but you know during service
when you in development its complex but
give you some comfort providing it as a
service with the default is another
story the level that we need to reach
and I will help you by the way we will
help you we will add us to be able to to
achieve it and to do it another things
also we have to be clear is that now
everybody understand that what you are
doing is absolutely critical for for
Europe and for our interest and our
sovereignty and see something which is
extremely put on for this commission and
from the state members so we will have
to to make more robust everything we are
doing including also of course a change
I mentioned already some of the elements
that we will have to cope with because
of our British friends decided to to
leave Europe and of course we are all
very sorry it's not what we wanted but
it's a fact and we have to expect the
wheel of the British waters of course
and we do respect it but we will have to
also as to take this into account we if
I know of course at UK zoom important
member of is a ok but the Commission is
an even more important member of Asia so
I will have to make sure that our
interests here which are partners of
course how well protected that's my job
nobody calls me to accept the job but
here I am and she's also one of the
reasons that I'm here
so we will walk but nicely huh
but taking everything in consideration
so another thing I wanted to to share
with you is that we need of course to
focus on more critical technologies that
you will use and I will have to turn to
rock on what are the critical
technologies that we will need to invest
in the future in your IRA which is
extremely important and then to decide
where to invest on how to invest that's
something that I don't have yet at my
level that's extremely important that
you can provide this and of course to
share with everyone so that we all agree
of of where we should put put our money
finally because I don't want to be too
long I said of course that and I make
sure my failures
what you did is amazing and nobody
believed that we will be able to provide
the realization and the services that
that we provide over the past 10 years
in space another good news that it's so
important that the staff member the
Commission decided to have a specific DG
defense and space which is something
totally new on its own that every single
member state understands that it how
critical it is to have this space
ongoing strategy but of course and one
of the reason I believe that I have
inherited what something could be a big
part for you because it's covering
services industry tourism but yeah
what kind of digital applications from
software to AI to HVC and then and 5g
and everything but also defense in space
everything is connected now everything
is interrelations and the key between
everything is of course data computing
power I'll probably why I decided to ask
me to do this and this is also why I
accepted to do it in other words it
means that we will need to work much
more together and especially in your
field but you'll know this but I will
make sure that you will get everything
you need and also that you change your
habits you need to share much more data
use much more HPC AI and work
differently with other colleagues maybe
not coming from the space industry but
which will help you to do what you have
to do and by the way without these
interconnections no future you know it I
know it so this is why not only I will
make sure that you will get everything
which is needed in this new paradigm and
that's a new paradigm including in term
of resources investment Roberto coming
from from the G connect and the program
that we may have but that will be
something extremely important extremely
important for me to make sure that that
we will be able to to get it and to
develop by the way a total industry not
only with big players which is great but
also with smart with SM is I see a lot
of promising Assamese already in this
environment including in some hard
technologies congratulation but also in
startups and and and this is where of
course we will we need to be it will be
one another way to give back all the
money that we receive from our fellow
European citizens and taxpayers so
thank you again for everything you do
thank you for accepting me at least the
one who are depending on me as the new
your new Commissioner or too bad for you
I don't know but see but it is the way
it is but there's one thing that I would
like you to know that I share your
passion I share your passion and my only
win and my only wish is to help you to
help us to do better to move faster and
to to become even more important because
everybody is waiting for us everyone is
watching us and we know our critical
what we are doing all together what we
do is for the shooter of Europe which is
another of our common passion thank you
[Applause]